let me start by saying i love this movie
i think uh kiva did such a great job
with this um so i
what i'm blown away by are the
characters that that the film is able to
use it was like i really couldn't
believe it and so i'm just curious for
you like which character or characters
were you like stunned that they managed
to get in this movie
probably ugly sonic
because me and akiva actually talked
about that because i mean of course like
you know once you get into the rights
and all of that it's kind of like who's
actually gonna make it
um so ugly sonic was definitely a that
was a fun fun gift that we have in this
film
is that was all of those was ugly sonic
and some of the other characters in the
film were they in it from like when you
first got the script or how much was
able to be added you know once you start
getting the rights i don't know exactly
you know just because i mean hey just
the actor left out of the loop
on a few of those things um but i do
believe ugly sonic was in in the
original script yeah he was because i
just thought that was hilarious that
they included that um but i mean that's
you know was that was something that was
also kind of fun about the film coming
together and just seeing you know
i don't know all of these studios and
all the people you know i'm sure that he
would have had to go to kind of say like
yeah okay you could put them in this
film that essentially is a celebration
of animation and you know and how far
it's come and the things that we love
and even the animation styles that we
were like why'd you guys do that
um so i think it's kind of cool to see
all of those characters kind of kind of
come together and even if we're poking
fun we're actually just celebrating all
of it 100 like and i i love the unkind
uncanny
valley animation thing like
there's so much it's it is a love letter
to animation it really is
so what was it like for you actually on
set because you're obviously interacting
with like tennis balls or whatever
you're interacting with and you have to
you know hit your mark while also trying
to you know act um so i'm just curious
what that was like for you it definitely
presented its challenges at times uh
because for the most part i never had a
real scene partner
um
so that was interesting uh but
thankfully akiva has such a clear vision
of what each scene was what every
character was doing so even though we
all were using a lot of our imagination
it was still very grounded because there
was so much clarity of what was
happening in each scene uh and then i
think we all just got to lean into
having fun the fun of playing
make-believe with chipmunks
and all the other characters we got to
play with i would imagine that the
background posters that are in the movie
are not in the script so what was it
like for you watching the movie and
because every background poster is a
joke so that's part of the fun of when a
film comes together but particularly
this film because there's some things
that were on the page you know that may
have changed but then there's some
things that were just a complete
surprise for me of like oh that's what
actually they added there because when i
was on set that was just a green screen
you know things like that so
this film in addition to being a love
letter to animation it's also a love
letter to imagination and just the
things that we can just
put together and like how imagination is
the seed of all of this storytelling for
all of these different characters like
your favorite animated character started
off as just a little idea in someone's
mind and so we get to celebrate all of
that as well and get all these little
easter eggs of all these little other
things you know that really i don't know
it's so nostalgic and just so fun i 100
agree i already got to go i'm just going
to say congrats on being part of a great
movie you know
have a great day thank you you too bye